[Music]
on this Sunday night the wounds of
War panic and Devastation as Israel
expands its assault in southern
Gaza the children who cannot escape the
Bloodshed and the civilians who say
there's nowhere to run how the climate
crisis is fueling a Health crisis we see
more heart attacks more Strokes during
those periods of high pollution Canadian
doctors Sound the Alarm about climate
induced sickness at cop 28 I'm just
curious if you would be willing to
answer in English point of order Madam
chair is just uh unacceptable a burning
question and a political Firestorm over
bilingualism friends forever thought of
him going even though he's just a puppy
right now breaks my heart a new drug
that could help large dogs live
longer global national with faren Asser
reporting Tonight Eric
senson
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with the Carnage in southern
Gaza and the chaos inside hospitals
struggling to cope as Israel intensifies
its assault further south doctors and
medical staff are at of Breaking Point
after8 weeks of Bloodshed and a brief
7-Day pause they're exhausted a warning
the video here is
disturbing Hospital corridors full of
children covered in blood shaken and SC
guard by the nightmare they are
living Israel has ordered people to
leave certain parts of Gaza for their
own safety after expanding its offensive
in the South targeting areas around con
Yunis where it believes many Hamas
leaders are hiding but the southern Gaza
Strip is also where civilians have
sought shelter in the last month and
many say there is nowhere left to go
that is safe Redmond Shannon has our top
story tonight and a warning some of the
images are
disturbing the
UNICEF calls this a war on children in
jabalia camp near Gaza City more kids
are confronted with grief and
pain my father and brother have been
killed says this
boy Israel says it has now launched
10,000 air strikes on Gaza since the
Hamas attacks of October 7th the focus
of those is moving
south the head of Israel's Defense Force
says the operation in the South will
match the north a spokesperson later
confirming troops are now on the ground
in the South it's an area previously
supposed to be the safer half of Gaza
this weekend can Yunis in the South
experienced what may have been its
heaviest bombing of the war so
far its hospitals under more strain than
ever Israel is now publishing maps to
instruct people where to go to stay
safe this man says he and his family are
fleeing for the fifth time in two months
insisting there is nowhere safe left the
recent week-long pause in fighting
already a distant memory they need to go
back to that pause humanitarian pause
ceasefire call it as as you want so that
you know the whole more positive
processes can start again including
putting a into Gaza to help people that
are at risk of their lives despite
growing if measured us pressure to
protect civilians in Gaza Israel says it
won't finish until it believes it has
eliminated Hamas part of that mission
includes destroying the tunnel Network
Israel claims is used by Hamas to
coordinate its operations Israel says it
has destroyed 500 of the 800 tunnel
shafts it has
found there is grief and fear fear in
Israel too even if in much smaller
numbers Soldier ashal Sama laid to rest
on Sunday and a synagogue in southern
Israel damaged by a rocket attack some
hopeful news though for people in Gaza
with links to
Canada 165 citizens permanent residents
and their families are on a new list of
those authorized to leave Gaza for Egypt
Eric Redmond Shannon tonight thank you
as Israel turns the focus of its
military operation from northern Gaza to
the South the UN says the number of
internally displaced Palestinians has
risen to 1.8 million close to 80% of the
population in other words about four out
of five people in Gaza have been forced
from their homes many are living in
tents makeshift shelters or sleeping on
the streets having moved to Southern
Gaza to escape Israel's initial bombing
campaign in the
North American officials are
investigating reports of attacks on a US
warship and Commercial vessels in the
Red Sea the Pentagon says it does not
believe the American warship was
intentionally targeted Yemen's houthi
Rebels claimed responsibility for the
attack in a televised statement saying
the group carried out a targeting
operation against two Israeli ships
Israel's military says those ships have
no connection to the state of
Israel in Paris a tourist was killed
near the Eiffel Tower Saturday night in
what France's president is calling a
terrorist
attack police say a 26-year-old French
national targeted a German couple with a
knife fatally injuring a 23-year-old man
later two others were attacked with a
hammer a suspect was then tasered by
police and arrested France's interior
Minister says the alleged attacker told
police he was upset over the crisis in
Gaza he previously served four years in
prison for planning violence he's also
on a security watch list and with was
undergoing psychiatric treatment a
warning some of the images in this next
story are graphic four people are dead
in the southern Philippines after a bomb
attack at a
university the blast happened during a
Catholic mass in a gymnasium 50 others
were also wounded Islamic State
militants claimed responsibility for the
attack which the Philippine president
says was perpetrated by Foreign
terrorists the attack happened in marawi
the largest musl Muslim City in the
predominantly Catholic country military
officials say it could be retaliation
following clashes with militants in the
surrounding
region at the cop 28 climate Summit in
Dubai there's renewed urgency for the
world to tackle climate change and cut
greenhouse gas emissions yet the
president and host of this year's Summit
is being criticized for new comments
saying there is quote no science behind
the need to phase out fossil fuels the
latest controversy comes as cop 28 is
making Health the f focus of the summit
for the very first time Abigail Bean
reports the head of cop 28 Under Fire
again there's no science out there or no
scenario out there that says that the
phase out of fossil fuel is what's going
to achieve 1.5 reported by the guardian
and Center for climate reporting Sultan
Al jabber made the comments in an online
event ahead of the summit he also
suggested there can't be a phase out of
fossil fuels alongside sustainable
development quote unless you want to
take the world back into caves many have
already called his position as head of
the United Arab emirat State Oil Company
a conflict of interest abusing The
public's trust by naming the CEO of one
of the largest and least responsible oil
companies in the world uh as head of the
cop this actually sounds very close to
climate denial language former
environment Minister Katherine McKenna
says she wants to see action at The
Summit in including a long awaited oil
and gas emissions cap from Canada and
when you hear the stories for small
island states that were literally be
underwater if we exceed 1.5 degrees it
is really ging when you hear the head of
the comp to say that we can't phase out
fossil fuels see if I can extract some
of these fossil fuels also looking for a
fossil fuel phase out commitment doctors
including Canadians taking part in the
first ever Health Focus day at cop we
see more heart attacks more Strokes
during those periods of high pollution
events um like a wildfire smoke day
Calgary ER Dr Joe vipon says Canadians
feel the effects of climate change
through everything from fires to high
temperatures to lime disease globally
the World Health Organization says heat
related deaths for people over 65
climbed by 75% in two decades to protect
Health from the impacts of climate
change we must recognize the linkages
between health and the environment and
articulate these impacts across all
sectors of our society Canada signed on
to the first ever climate and health
declaration at cop also suay a $5
million contribution from Canada to help
the poorest countries become climate
resilient Abigail ban global news
Ottawa Quebec entrepreneur Danielle Lis
and his wife Dominique Maron have
reportedly been found dead on the
Caribbean island of Dominica langis is
known for founding soft image a digital
effects company used in several
blockbuster movies according to local
news reports their bodies were found in
a charred vehicle on Friday Lang nois
and Marshon owned a luxury resort on the
island Global Affairs Canada says it's
aware of the deaths of two Canadians in
Dominica but would not confirm their
identities there's more political
Fallout tonight over the use of
bilingualism in this country after a
conservative MP asked the Heritage
minister to reply to a question last
week in English that moment has incited
plenty of reaction especially in Quebec
a province where the conservatives are
trying to make inroads while the premier
is trying to protect the French language
Tim Sergeant reports I'm just curious if
you would be willing to answer in
English point of order Madam chair that
one question created an immediate
political Firestorm of reaction the fact
that the conservative party is demanding
that um a member only use one language
to me is just uh unacceptable
conservative MP Raquel Thomas asking
Heritage minister Pascal s whose mother
tongue is French to answer a question in
English during a Committee hearing for
the conservatives to put in question
official bilingualism the leader of the
blocka writing on social media that
bilingualism in Canada is the
frankophone who switches to English on
demand adding in quotes speak white a
reference to a poem with the same name
about the oppression of frankophones in
Canada the issue comes at a time when
language has once again become a hot
political Topic in Quebec
the premier is doubling down on
protecting and promoting the French
language passing at least one law that
strengthens the use of French in the
workplace and trying to FastTrack
another that someone could threaten the
use of English in the Health Care System
well it's unfortunate this advocate for
protecting English in Quebec says a
language request made at the federal
level by an MP for a colleague to answer
a question in English has ramifications
in Quebec where the English-speaking
population is frequently battling to
protect their minority rights certainly
this kind of thing does not help us and
we expect our members of parliament to
support our minority language Community
some analysts say the issue has put the
conservatives in damage control in
Quebec this complicates the situation
for uh for pi in Quebec political
observers say the conservatives will
have to support the use of French in
Quebec if they hope to make a big push
at the next federal election they will
have to you know emphasize B langual ISM
and the need to protect French because
if they want to win seats in Quebec more
seats in Quebec they have to emphasize
this while language may not be a top
priority issue for most quebecers it's
always a lightning rod and politicians
will likely continue to try and spin
this latest language issue for their
political gain Tim Sergeant Global News
Montreal surging rent prices in Nova
Scotia coming up how it's fueling more
criticism during a worsening housing
crisis plus the ongoing search for a
missing marsupial in Ontario why
concerns for this runaway kangaroo are
growing according to statistics Canada
rent inflation in Nova Scotia is the
highest in the country and the highest
it's ever been since the agency started
tracking that data in 1979 this as Nova
Scotia struggles with homelessness
housing Advocates and landlords alike
blame the province for failing to act
but as Heidi petk explains they have
very different ideas on finding a
solution when Lisa hay hurst's holiday
decorations come down her rent will go
up it's gone up so much each year um now
it's going up to I think 5.1% in the New
Year Nova scotia's rent cap changes from
2% to 5 and heyer's budget will tighten
once I pay my rent there's not a lot
left over compared to the same time last
year rents in Nova Scotia increased more
in October than anywhere else in Canada
the rate of rent inflation hit just over
14% the next highest Alberta at 99.6%
British Columbia and Quebec both at 8.8
even though Supply uh has increased like
in Nova Scotia we've seen the highest
completion rate of rental units but
demand has been uh Stronger that's
because more people are moving into
Halifax which also means the capital's
homeless population has grown what I see
when people come in is a lot of people
who are really scared the real culprit
he says provincial regulations allowing
landlords to end a fixed term lease for
one tenant and sign another up for the
same unit at a higher rent so this
totally undermines the bargaining power
uh of tenants and the the usefulness of
the rent cap while landlords say they're
squeezed between inflation and the rent
cap what happens the rents go up in the
newer units because they're subsidizing
the rent control units they have to make
the the the the economics work with most
cases brought in front of the tency
board for non-payment of rent Russell
says what's needed is extra financial
help for tenants but the province isn't
budging it says its rent cap is only
temporary while also admitting fixed
term leases are being used for quote
unintended purposes but it's made no
indication it plans to change either one
Heidi pic Global News
[Music]
Halifax ahead just how much can the
Liberals improve their political
fortunes by potentially replacing their
leader in the wake of recent polling
that showed three out of four Canadians
want prime minister Justin Trudeau to
step down some Liberals are wondering if
they might do better in the next
election with a new leader in new
polling provided exclusively to Global
News ipsos exist examined that
proposition and it looks unlikely that
there is a savior on the horizon our
chief political correspondent David Aken
reports
David it is the Deputy Prime Minister
chrisa Freeland whose name is most often
mentioned as a possible replacement for
Justin Trudeau and we asked her last
week what she thought about that we have
a great prime minister and my focus is
100% on supporting the Prime Minister we
also asked treasury board president
Anita Anand if she wanted to be
leader you think she didn't think much
of the question but ipsos asked
Canadians how much more likely they
might be to vote liberal with a new
leader just 25% said more likely with
Freeland in charge 21% with foreign
affairs minister Melanie Jolie 18% with
former Bank of Canada Governor Mark
Carney 177% with onand and 16% with
industry Minister franois phip champagne
at the helm but none of those potential
leaders would bring in enough voters to
the Liberals to eliminate the huge lead
the conservatives had there's nothing
there there's no Silver Lining that
anybody can really uh grab on that
suggests that there's a any pathway
through to improving these situations
that's not to say the Liberals aren't
trying to improve the numbers one of the
liberal party's campaign co-chairs says
one way the the party will do that is by
focusing a little less on Trudeau and
highlight others to sell the liberal
brand I think we have a great team now
too and people can see that I think
Canadians will see other players on this
team in any event Trudeau himself is
telling anyone who asks that he is
spoiling for a showdown with
conservative leader Pierre PV and
Trudeau is confident of a fourth
consecutive Victory and that is
something only John a McDonald and
Wilford Lord have ever done David aen
Global News
Ottawa what would you do for more time
with your furry friend the drug that
could add a year to your dog's life
coming up on global
national all
right
tonight sweet
as miles Goodwin the longtime lead
singer of Canadian band April Wine has
died at the age of 75 Goodwin lived in
the Halifax area and fronted the band
for more than 50 years famous for hits
like you could have been a lady and
Roland the band was inducted into
Canada's Walk of Fame earlier this
year in Ontario it's day four of the
search for a runaway kangaroo that
escaped while a delivery driver was
transporting two kangaroos to Quebec
they stopped at the oswa zoo to let them
stretch their legs say police but one of
them jumped over the Handler's heads
dozens of people have since spotted The
Fugitive marsupial but she remains on
the loose and there is growing concern
as the weather gets colder Searchers
believe the kangaroo is tired and Afraid
and may be Sheltering out of sight to
try to keep warm if spotted the message
is to call Animal Control Officers and
do not approach the
kangaroo advice you don't hear very
often in this country it's said to be
the sad part of pet ownership no matter
how long they live it always feels like
your forced to say goodbye far too soon
researchers have been looking for ways
to extend the lifespan of pets and as
Heather yorx West explains they appear
to be on the verge of a
breakthrough he's only 9 months old but
wy's family knows any time spent with
this good boy will be precious dog years
are few thought of him going even though
he's just a puppy right now breaks my
heart for large breed dogs where
lifespans can be as short as 5 to 8
years the Heartbreak comes quick but
what if that could change we are working
on extending the healthy lifespan of
large and giant breed dogs so thank
Great Dan Bernie's mountain dogs even I
have a sleeping rot across from me this
week the US Food and Drug Administration
found that the drug developed by loyal a
biotech company based in California had
a reasonable expectation of
Effectiveness a major hurdle cleared as
the company Works to bring the first
first ever longevity drug for dogs to
Market what the drug does is tampers
down the signaling of this growth
hormone igf-1 it slows that rate of
Aging to levels that are already
healthily seen in smaller dogs um to
hopefully give them more healthy years
but the development raises ethical
questions too just because you could
prolong your dog's life does that mean
you should when I first read the news I
found it absolutely fascinating um but
then all of a sudden I had had a flurry
of questions and concerns bod rocket
Wolfie go man go dog trainer and
behaviorist Brad Patterson says he
worries about the quality of life dogs
would experience in those last prolonged
years where large breeds are more likely
to experience hip dysplasia or arthritis
pain I think it's a great milestone for
longevity companies in general because
loyal is not the only biotech company
pursuing longevity therapies work is
underway for for human treatments too
and the science is close within 10 to 15
years we might see some uh combinatorial
therapies that can Target multiple
organs and maybe provide some degree of
systemic Rejuvenation or systemic
delaying of
Aging the promise of longer lives for
both people and their four-legged
friends could be realized soon Heather
urex West Global News
Calgary more ethical questions about our
pets and that's global national for this
Sunday night I'm Eric senson tonight's
your Canada is the British Columbia
legislature in Victoria we love seeing
your Canada please email your photos to
viewers at
global.com Jeff simple will be at the
anchor desk tomorrow thanks for
watching